foreign
oh no I have lost my way
whatever shall I do
all right guys I'm in the middle of
nowhere here in Alaska and I'm going to
show you how not to freeze to death if
you're stranded in the woods in the
wintertime first things first we gotta
start moving some snow
the snow is never all the same there's
layers of powder and layers of crusty
ice you can cut up the Crusty isolators
with the knife
you're gonna move a whole lot more snow
if you can take it out in blocks rather
than handfuls
all right we got down to the ground and
cleared out a section about the size of
a queen mattress looks pretty good it's
got to be hard well draining soil we've
got frozen mud standing water ice any of
that stuff you gotta change spots you're
not going to last if you try to sleep in
the mud or sleep on the ice a little bit
more slope than I'd like but I'll take
it I think it's time for a little snack
break my wife made me a block of butter
coconut mochi hmm it's a Japanese
Hawaiian dish made with rice flour
butter and loads of sugar it's got like
a bazillion calories and stays fresh
forever
it's a great Trail food
just save this for later
this right here is a dead Paper Birch
you can see this little papery bark that
is an excellent fire starter and that's
how we're going to get our Tinder for
our flint and steel got to make really
sure not to stick this in the snow
though
foreign
keep all these snowflakes off our Tinder
and I cut this birch bark and try to get
this really fine stuff for Tinder
a nice little pile of dry bark
oh there we go
oh that is gonna go up quick
the heat from this is intense it's hard
to stand next to this thing we've got to
thaw the ground out if we sleep on warm
dry ground it'll make all the difference
in the world so I've got to build a
massive fire and I gotta keep it going
for a long time
foreign
check it out we got a bunch of water
right here can't sleep in that
well the fire has done a great job
thawing the ground out and pushing the
walls of the shelter back but we're
getting water pooling up here and here
now hopefully once the ground gets a
little more thawed that water will just
go straight down it won't be a problem
but if we can't get rid of that standing
water I'm gonna have to make a raised
bed and that's going to be a lot of work
cutting to do but I'm gonna get a start
on dinner I'm gonna be making some baked
beans
all right
got a bag of Great Northern beans here
dump them in there
gonna let those beans simmer and soak
for a couple hours while we work on our
shelter
[Music]
all right I'm gonna move the fire and
see if the ground's drying up at all
if anything it's muddier
you see all the snow and ice it's
melting is just draining straight down
into this corner
and to a lesser extent we got it going
on over in this corner too I'm hoping if
I can dig little trenches on either side
then the water will go out this way and
I can make the middle nice and dry so I
have a place to sleep we'll see what
happens but this is the problem in the
winter time you really don't know what
type of ground you're dealing with until
you get it all shoveled out and thought
out the ideal place to do this is like a
gravel bar or a sand dune or a beach on
a lake
but you don't always get what you want
so you just gotta adapt
[Music]
I want to make a platform to sleep on
and to do that I need to get rid of all
these little branches I don't have an ax
and doing that with my knife will take
forever so I'm gonna use the fire
foreign
there we go dry ground
my little gutter trick seems to be
working we got firm dry ground right
here
all right we're getting there
foreign
got a little sleeping platform to keep
me out of the mud and it's a little bit
softer than the ground the wood bends a
little bit
got this just in case it starts to snow
really bad tonight I can throw my
blanket over the top and use it like a
tarp well I think my beans are about
done and I've worked up quite an
appetite so I think it's time to make
some dinner now I know this is a
survival video but I have a very
important rule I live by I don't mind
being cold I don't mind sleeping on the
ground and I don't mind being hungry but
I only do one of those things at a time
so tonight I'm eating like a king
time to cut up some firewood
oh
my blanket got a little wet from the
snowstorm so I'm just drying it out also
kind of makes a nice little Windbreak in
my back
all right let's test the beans
nice and soft
add a little pepper add a little salt
add some ground mustard
brown sugar and tomato paste
beans are almost done so I'm gonna go
ahead and make some bread I have this
dough I made up last night
take and wrap
this bit of cheese a little bit of bread
dough with that gouda inside
eating bread on the coals is really easy
either you make a disc and you lay it
straight on the coals and flip it or you
make a ball and you bury it into coals
a little bit of campfire actually gets
stuck to the bread tastes just like
flour
coming along nicely
all right we're gonna put that right on
the coals
just like the bread the coals are going
to stick to it while it's rare and once
it's cooked the colds will fall off
yes that is perfect
a little cheese filled biscuit cooked in
the ash right there
oh
she got the melted gouda in there that
is so good
oh those are good beans it's got so much
pork jowls in there and the brown sugar
these are good beans
oh that is delicious steak
this bread dough is so easy to bring on
winter campouts you just tear off a
piece and bake yourself some fresh bread
whenever you're feeling like it
if you refrigerate it it'll last three
four days without any problems it just
slowly becomes sour dough if you let it
sit for too long
I'll have bread was good I'm gonna make
some more of that
that is good prime rib nice glue
oh look at that
that's gorgeous
but it looks like it's going to be windy
and cold tonight
dinner was really good but I am so
thirsty so I need to clean my pot out
and start melting some snow get some
water
foreign
well the wind is really kicking up and
it is getting cold and the sun's setting
and I don't have enough firewood to get
me through the night so I need to go and
start chopping some more wood
well there we go that's a healthy pile
of firewood and I got a bunch of Tinder
over here as well
this Pine Burns about one inch radius
per hour it's about a two and a half
three inch radius so this piece of wood
should last three hours in the fire you
need about four of these to have a fire
so I'm gonna burn up about four of these
logs every three hour so I have about 12
hours of firewood right there
foreign
got my water
my socks are all sweaty I'm gonna go
ahead and try to dry my feet and boots
off before I go to sleep I got all the
steam coming off my feet
yeah my socks are really wet
oh that makes such a difference
my feet are all dry I got all my
firewood I think it's time to go to bed
I'm gonna be waking up throughout the
night to stoke the fire so better get to
bed sooner rather than later but before
I go to bed I'm going to show you one
little trick that's going to make my bed
very warm
thank you
well there we go got my bed set up where
my fire used to be they got all those
hot coals and Hot Rocks underneath there
it's gonna be so toasty warm oh wow yeah
that is awesome now if you're gonna do
this you want to make sure you use a
real wool blanket I did this with a
synthetic blanket or a polyester blanket
it would melt and cause me all sorts of
problems
nice and warm I can feel the heat from
the ground coming up through the bed it
is really nice
I'll tell you what it is so toasty in
here I'm low enough that the snow berm
is blocking the wind I've got the heat
from the ground coming up underneath me
and this fire is just baking me but I'm
gonna have to get up and soak the fire
several times throughout the night
so I better get going to bed
it's gonna be a long night I'll see you
in the morning
oh good morning
well there you go I didn't freeze to
death I even got some sleep was it
comfortable not particularly did I have
to Wing up a lot and soak the fire yeah
but it's pretty warm in here
oh had a little bit of snow last night
you know I woke up with these snowflakes
hitting my face which is really annoying
when you're trying to sleep I was able
to pull my face under the blanket and
stay dry but my blade gets a little bit
wet so I think I better dry it out
all right I think next step is to soak
the fire up and get some coals going so
we can make breakfast
all right I think it's time to cook some
breakfast
I got some leftover dough some leftover
pork chow bacon and a jar of honey and
butter
I think we're gonna make something good
all right I got honey and melted butter
like a little bit of pork gel bacon here
honey butter
[Music]
fresh bread slabs of bacon smothered in
honey butter this is nice
that is so good
oh I'll tell you what guys I've built a
lot of lean twos and Bushcraft shelters
but hands down the best way to stay warm
is to build a big fire clear out the
snow dry out the ground then move the
fire over and sleep on the warm ground
if you get really cold you can switch
places with the fire throughout the
night but unfortunately you need to be
able to make fire and you need access to
a lot of firewood for this to work and
if you don't have that there's another
trick I've heard about when I was a boy
my grandfather told me a story about a
Native American woman in his community
who got lost in the mountains crazy
blizzard came in dumped multiple feet of
snow deadly cold and when this Native
American woman realized that she was
stuck in this blizzard she found a tree
went under the branches and went to
sleep and so what my grandpa told me is
that you don't freeze to death without
waking up at least once and so when
she'd wake up cold instead of ignoring
it and going back to sleep she'd pop up
and run around the tree until her blood
was going and she was hot and then she
would go back under the tree go back to
sleep Apparently after two days the
blizzard broke and the community went up
into the mountains looking for and there
they found her and she just been running
around this tree for two days she was
tired miserable and cold but she was
alive but the more survival Bushcraft
camping trips I do the more I realized
that this survival stuff is really a lot
of work you're gonna have to push
yourself for hours every day just to
make it if you're not willing to work
hard and if you don't have that
self-discipline you're just not gonna
get it done
but on that note I think it's time to
start packing up
oh
just blows me away how good of a job
that fire does in clearing away the snow
it actually reminds me of the Donner
Party they had a fire pit like this and
it snowed 15 feet on them and the wall
of their fire pit was so high that they
had to carve stairs to be able to get in
and out of the fire pit well guys
hopefully you enjoyed this if you want
to see more videos like this check out
the outdoor Boys YouTube channel we put
out new videos every Saturday morning
and we have entire playlists of just our
survival camping videos
all right guys I'll see you next
Saturday morning if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching
[Music]